i'm dave rubin we are live on rumble on
youtube and on blaze tv and welcome to
our first round table of 2022
feeling very sharp today because we're
doing a florida
spectacular that's right we're going to
be discussing why the free state of
florida is just so absolutely
wonderful my linen suit is getting dry
cleaned as you can imagine so this is my
second best miami outfit
joining me is a senior fellow at the
claremont institute david reboy
political commentator john cardillo and
new york post and fox news columnist
carol markowitz david john carroll
floridians welcome to the reuben report
great to be here it is good to see you
guys uh we are all floridians in
different parts of florida here i'll
take the sunglasses off now that i made
my point i am here on the beach this is
obviously completely real um
john i want to start with you because
you've been here the longest you are a
new york guy originally just like me you
were in the nypd you lived that
northeast life you came down here
what it's about 18 years ago i guess
what sent you down here originally and
has it been for these last 18 years
it's been awesome and so yeah so i got
here two weeks will be 18 years and i
got here february 23rd
2004. for me it was a little bit
different it wasn't this mass migration
we're seeing now
the politics and lockdowns i just got
sick of that general malaise that was
over new york city post 9 11. you know
bloomberg was mayor he started to
regulate fruit punch
so you can kind of see
literally right you can kind of see the
end at the end it was uh
approaching but i also didn't want to
live and die in the same place my whole
life i grew up in queens
manhattan and i just wanted to change
and fall in love with south florida and
here i am 18 years later yeah and now
you've got like a ranch and horses and
you're just living the floridian
lifestyle as we can see by your current
location uh reboy you got down here a
couple years ago after doing 15 years in
dc and dc i used to love dc i mean truly
truly love that city it is a dystopian
nightmare right now
can you talk about why why you left dc
and what it's been like these last
couple years in florida sure
sure sure i mean dc has always been a
great place to visit and it was a
it was an okay place to live
but around
2018 i started coming down here to uh
to miami beach and my my family
lives down here for the last 20 years
and and uh
and my i kind of grew up around here
around this neighborhood because my
grandparents
lived here as well so we used to come
down and visit
and in 2018 i started coming down with
more frequency and realizing that i
hated it every time i had to go back
so i just said you know what the heck
with it i'm gonna i'm just gonna move to
florida and when i did i was
you know i was kind of alone um you know
people were like why are you moving to
florida you're gonna be completely
disconnected from from life
and uh and it was fine it was great
until kovic came along and then when
kovac came along everybody started to
see what
um you know what a great place florida
is and now
you know
now i feel like it's over because we've
we've been completely uh you know
overtaken i mean you know no no offense
to you guys but we've been completely
overtaken by uh by by new residents
filling up yeah all right i want to
address that actually because i think
there's a it's a really important thing
to talk about about you know when you do
something right and then you get new
people fleeing to make sure that they
don't change it so i do want to get to
that and reboy i know you're really not
happy about the miami traffic so let's
hold that for just a sec carol you just
got here i think basically like the same
week that i got here i bumped into you
at the airport actually when we were
going to something uh a little north um
you left brooklyn you couldn't take it
anymore it had a lot to do with your
kids right
yeah
so i have three kids um lifelong new
yorker and you know kind of the joke
also is that when my husband and i would
talk about like if we had to leave new
york and this is you know five years ago
or so like we had to leave new york
where would we go and los angeles was
always our second choice and you know
see how that turned out um so
yeah you know around summer 2020 we
started talking about like how crazy
everything was getting and how we might
have to go my husband and i are both
immigrants so it's sort of been part of
our family story that when things get
bad you you have to bounce and um we saw
things getting bad and we saw that our
kids weren't going to have the life that
we had envisioned for them we had just
finished like building our dream house
we were completely committed to staying
in brooklyn until the kids went to
college we were going to retire to
manhattan we had a whole plan
but things just got crazier and crazier
and florida
was so clearly
the normal promised land i mean that's
really what florida has become to people
like it's 2019 in the best possible way
yeah and you know i so feel you on that
because first off i was born in brooklyn
i spent most of my life in new york city
but on the dream house thing we had just
moved into our dream house i could have
never left that place where boy you'd
been there it was pretty awesome um and
it's at some point it's time to get out
of dodge but i want to address what
david said about
this sort of new influx and everything
so john you've been here as i said 18
years uh you got you were early in um
what are the are there are there
negatives to having this new crew move
in i mean i've met a ton of people who
fully get it including carol like the
new people who are coming who are like
we're here to keep florida florida et
cetera but it does create some problems
in terms of house prices traffic etc etc
[Music]
yeah i mean look the traffic's always
been bad the traffic's always been bad
it's all relative so i lived down in
brickell when i first came here and i
moved because as brickell was i got
there on all four days and there was
nothing the brickell you see today and
for your viewers i don't know what that
is it's downtown miami the hotter part
of downtown miami there was nothing
there at all there was nothing i think
the tallest building was the four
seasons tower a couple of condo
buildings i lived in one and that was
about it so when they started really
blowing that out traffic became insane i
moved up to fort lauderdale area about
seven years ago but it's all relative
i don't really notice
a massive difference in the traffic i if
you can that i go up to palm beach
county pretty much every day i was up
there for an early breakfast this
morning it hadn't been too horrible but
then again i know the area so i know how
to get off of i-95 and use the turnpike
or us-1 so once you get used to living
here there are ways around it but i love
the growth and it's a guy who owns some
investment properties here i just hope
the uh
real estate
well as a guy that just bought a happy
club yeah as a guy that just bought a
house i can tell you uh if you had a
house here before you're you're doing
pretty well uh dave but i know you've
been you've been sort of uh making a
stink about the traffic situation it's
kind of funny for me coming from la
where the traffic is horrible and you
can't even tell where people are going
here it's like they're constructing new
roads everywhere you can see it's a city
that is being born again but i do have
sympathy for the people that have been
here and and then it suddenly gets
really congested yeah i mean i i don't
know i i can see it i've been kind of
watching it over the last uh over the
last two years especially since covet
trips that would take i mean i you know
i
when there's no traffic i go to
one of my gyms at in eight minutes
these days it can take up to all about
an hour
and i've seen it
steadily increase
and um you know yes i live on the beach
so it's you know so that that makes it
hard there are only you know limited
number of
you know places where you can go to get
off the beach but still it's it's just
an amazing amount of congestion
um i mean in addition to the traffic of
course as you you noted you know there's
uh there's the the housing prices
which are pushing everyone who is middle
class
further and further out you know to the
point where it's just um i think it's
just increasingly going to be not
sustainable
um
miami itself is an interesting case
because
uh
you know
the the white flight from miami happened
in the
80s and the early 90s so that's not it's
not even an an an issue of that i mean
right now it's uh you know it's it's
cubans and hispanics that are getting
priced out
of
you know of uh of really anywhere in uh
in almost anywhere in dade county
and um
it's just uh it's
we're going to have to figure out you
know those of us on the right who
believe in
you know free markets and things like
that need to wrap our
heads around
uh gentrification and urbanism because
we haven't we haven't really figured
this out um in a way that is that is
sustainable i mean we don't want what
happened to austin what happened to san
francisco what happened to new york
to happen to uh to miami yeah and that's
actually exactly why i brought it up
because i do think that with all of us
new people coming as wonderful as it is
we do have to be sensitive to the people
that got it right and have been here and
i do sense that not only through
desantis obviously but but suarez and
some of the other mayors that they are
going to hopefully deal with as many of
these things but i do want to call
attention to it carol has anything been
a problem for you here people keep
asking me in all my q and a's dave it
can't just be as great as you say it is
and
honestly for me yeah it is i haven't had
any problems whatsoever yeah it's been
amazing i really i also i
look i'm trying to be very realistic
about this nowhere is perfect so sort of
my running joke has been like the
sushi's bad here but we've actually had
like two incredible sushi meals recently
which are new york quality and i was
very impressed and i don't even have
that anymore to like fall back on i
guess chinese food they still need to
kind of work on chinese food here um but
other than that like i can't think of
anything um i i mentioned this i mean
i think to some of you but
schools florida schools have a really
bad reputation outside of florida
and i don't understand why i'm finishing
up a book right now but i'm gonna take a
deep dive into that at some point
because i don't get it the kid the
public schools that my kids go to in
florida are so good and so responsive
and um
so catering to their
extremely unique needs like i have one
child who is just extremely advanced and
i have another child sort of behind
and i have another child who just like
has really esoteric interests and
they're like really tailoring everything
to each one of them individually and i'm
extremely impressed and i don't get what
i'm missing and maybe it's just like oh
my kids have been to good schools here
um that's definitely possible but i i
think that i really would love to learn
more about why florida schools sort of
do have a poor reputation i think it's
partly because the taxes are low here so
people automatically think that means
there isn't enough money to go to the
schools and it simply is not true where
i'm in the suburbs over here where
everyone keeps telling us how great all
the schools are uh so all right we've
whittled it down that the big problems
here are there's a little bit of traffic
and a salmon avocado roll could be hard
to come by so i think it's doing all
right but obviously all of this has a
little something to do with the guy
that's been in charge for the last
couple years
we all had the pleasure of having dinner
at the governor's mansion with ron
desantis about a month and a half ago
totally open it was off the record
conversation so we're not going to
repeat anything that was said but just
struck me as just like a really really
decent guy who does not want to be king
that was my main takeaway of the night
like he does not want to rule over
people he'd like people to be free we
could have pulled a gajillion clips of
him doing it right over the last two
years we've got this one on
children and masks and mandates take a
look these kids are so much happier
being able to go to school without
having to wear masks for eight hours a
day so when you start to see them kind
of re-evaluate or say all this just
understand this the science didn't
change well the medical science didn't
change
the political science change they feel
the heat they know that voters have been
tired of perpetual lockdown policies
they know that they have basically
offered no off ramp and they know that
they're fixing to get whooped at the
poles and so that's what's causing the
epiphany but the fact of the matter is
if they had looked at the actual science
from the beginning
they would have known that this was
something that florida was right on
carol let me start with you on that one
because you basically moved here for
your kids as we talked about a second
ago um can you just talk about you know
having them out of the masks be free
just their general state i read a study
yesterday or the day before about the
speech issues that kids are now having
because literally their mouth muscles
are not developing the way they are
supposed to and they can't see the
teacher's mouths so they can't mimic
things and it's going to delay speech
for years
that is it's just like anybody who's
ever met a child knew that was gonna
happen like i don't understand how
that's even like news you know but so
many people were ringing that alarm for
so long um and we were obviously all
dismissed but you know about the
governor like i feel very defensive of
him i i do get into like arguments all
the time on his behalf and it is not
because i like him as a politician
although yes i do um it's because i feel
like he he stands up for literally me
like for me for my family i feel like
he's actually in the fight like to help
us specifically i i don't i really can't
think of a situation where i felt that
way before like the only like even
comparable thing to me is like how much
i credited rudy giuliani with turning
new york city around and how i felt like
that made a real tangible difference in
my life that i could ride the subway at
night or you know any number of things
and this is like the only time in my
life where i think a politician has had
such a direct effect on what happens in
my life and on behalf of my children
that i just feel like i have to
constantly go to bat for him because he
is protecting me and i think i i owe him
the same kind of protection and it's
it's as a constituent not as a
journalist i i feel very strongly for
him as a constituent yeah i i feel the
same way john when we were talking to
him and again we can't say anything that
that was private not not that we said
anything that shouldn't have been said
publicly but that was just the nature of
the of the dinner um the thing that
really struck me was how
he kind of was just like yeah i just
didn't feel that i should listen to
group think and i should do what i
thought was right like that's kind of
how i want to lead that in essence was
was it like that's pretty freaking
special these days huh
yeah and i love that carol waited ron de
santa giuliani because you know i say
this often on social media
those are two guys who hate politicians
and if you hate politicians
you're a good politician i've always
said the next the next republican
president that comes in and it's
conservative should find a
a pool of people who hate doj fbi cia
nsa and whoever that pool hates those
agencies the most there's your secretary
there's your director and i think a guy
like desantis hates bureaucracy i i you
know i've been around his team and him
for many years operating politically
down here in florida and they are they
aren't just a political they're
anti-political in fact i had a
conversation that night with his chief
of staff and and uh it's something
he said very publicly
ron desantis isn't beholden to polls he
doesn't make decisions based on polling
he makes them based on science and
what's best for the people of the state
of florida his constituents or when he
was a congressman his congressional
district
we need more like that and carol's 100
right he is an act for her for me for
use for
dave you've been i think it's i think
it's interesting that four of us now
lived in
you know all four of us here lived in
new york city under giuliani
and all of us you know are obviously
here under desantis and and that
parallel that that you know carol
and and and and john mentioned was
absolutely apt
um you know there's no better
uh you know there's no better analog for
it in uh in in american politics
certainly
not
you know in in any city
you know where i
so the million-dollar question that
everybody's asking is you know is he
gonna run for president and i hate doing
too much i like just like the racehorse
politics kind of thing but i've been
very clear about this a couple times on
the show and on twitter i don't want him
to run for president i think the
governor matters way more i would like
to keep this state right let's keep
modeling this thing right you know he's
only been governor for a couple years
it's not even like he's been doing this
for that long it's like let's keep this
right i also think biden is so damaged
that whether it's trump or whoever it's
like there's a really good chance and
and obviously the midterms seem like
they're gonna make some sense or at
least you know push some of this wave of
insanity back a bit are you guys with me
on that i mean do you want him to stay
here do you want him to run i guess how
does that get complicated by trump dave
i'll go to you first i mean look i i in
many ways i agree with you
um he does more good here especially
considering what has happened in the
last uh you know let's say what's what's
happened in the last decade
um to prove that
what happens in washington is is you
know frankly unchangeable you know the
administrative state the character of
our regime
uh has changed to the point where the
administrative state runs the show and i
don't really think it's possible to uh
you know to to make fundamental change
uh while while in washington i think
that that door is is closed but here in
florida as you said there's a lot that
you can do now i you know
ron desantis i think has done everything
right he is he has served also as a
beacon for
other
red state uh uh governors especially to
look around and say this is these are
the things that are possible and
i think
i think definitely after he's uh he
emerges from his re-election victorious
i think people are going to say oh okay
um you know this is a path that uh that
is is is sort of worth taking which is
um
you know which is to sort of model
themselves after him um and and the way
he's governing in
in in florida
um i mean i that could be the best case
scenario is having a bunch of
really good governors in red states
uh sort of pushing things to the right
yeah i agree that's how we fix this john
what do you think you want him to stay
sh do do we need do we need him out
front nationally
his name is out there nationally now
he's got hundreds of millions of dollars
in brand id
because of his leadership on kobet but
he's 43 years old he has all the time in
the world to make this decision i just
want to see him win in a landslide here
in florida in november because we need
it there's only one statewide elected
democrat in florida florida has a
cabinet so there are six statewide
elected positions in florida a few
viewers are two u.s senators our
governor attorney general cfo
and agriculture secretary well nikki
freed is a disaster she's our ag
secretary she is an epic disaster has
been for years she's going to stay about
elected democrat i think she's going to
get trounced in her primary against
charlie crist but if she does either one
of them charlie crist or nikki freed it
is going to be a bloodletting in the
general
desantis is going to just destroy it and
that's what i want to see what he does
after that i don't know because 2024 is
an eternity that's a long time away in
politics but again 43 years old he has
all the time in the world really the
ball is in his court man he has all the
cards
are on the table for him at this point
carol i sense we're going to make this a
clean sweep on this issue here i don't
know
i'm gonna be a little bit uh just a
little contrarian
yeah you know the thing is that i have
changed my mind since becoming a florida
resident which is i i before moving here
i was like desantis 2024 for sure um and
now obviously i see the benefit of
having him as my governor um but i kind
of you know i agree with so many things
that uh both john and dave said and and
you um
that for example you can't do very much
in dc and um
you know i i fully agree with that but i
kind of want to see what a ron desantis
somebody who i feel like is actually
effective again going back to like i
don't think we've had that many
effective politicians like ever in any
state um so having an effective
politician as president like i don't
know what would that be like that's
exciting um and the thing is while i
agree that he's young i think everybody
has their moment and we can call this
the chris christie rule
and if you don't seize your moment you
might miss it so
if
ron desantis is going to pursue the
presidency i i kind of do think it has
to be in 2024 um and that you know i
have mixed feelings about that now i
agree completely can i add something
to that you know yeah i agree with carol
wholeheartedly in so far as the samus
has really really
changed the game and raised the bar with
regards to personnel look at his choice
of florida surgeon general
no
on the uh on the democratic side in
florida wanted doctor latico because
he's effective and brilliant and like
desantis doesn't care about polls and
politics if he brought that to dc and
i'll disagree with dave slightly uh
reboy
you can affect change in dc if you're
truly willing to drain the swamp not to
use a cliche if you understand that it's
beyond just changing the heads of
agencies appointing your own people
you can't fire the gs9s 11 12 13 14 15.
but you sure can break those agencies
off that's what a president can do you
can tell people at the state department
who love their dinners in georgetown
sorry screw you you're moving to omaha
you can tell the department of the
interior the same you're going to south
dakota and then you start moving the
visions of these agencies to places
where the dc elites working there don't
want to live
they'll quit you start filling those
positions with everyday americans more
red americans that's where a president
can affect change and i think the census
is smart enough and strong enough to do
that personnel is policy
and unfortunately that was one of
trump's weak spots i don't think
desantis has that same weakness i think
he will weaponize personnel in a very
effective way like he's done with dr
latifah in florida
dave are you as bullish on that idea or
do you just think the machinery in
washington no matter how effective and
clever and you know bringing in all the
right people desantis does all that
stuff has the right ideas that just the
machinery in washington just wouldn't
allow it to happen regardless
yeah i yeah i don't i don't think it's i
don't think it's possible i mean it's a
great idea to move some of these
agencies but um
you know let's let's let's see it happen
the people that would be responsible for
moving these agencies to other places
would be the same people that you've got
to fight with
um it would be
you know the the one of the problems
that we have let's say on the right is
that we just don't have a bench when it
comes to this stuff um you know the
trump administration was notoriously
awful in figuring out who to appoint
but
and they appointed a lot of you know the
horrible folks that that
that made life very tough for them but
they still didn't feel you know anywhere
close to the 15 000 um
political appointments that uh that they
had to fill i mean it just it you know a
lot of these things just left uh were
left
unfilled because there is a gap
um there there we we have not yet
we have not yet built the institutions
uh that sort of supply these people
uh because they're not there is not an
infinite infinite number of uh
of folks who can be bureaucrats even
good bureaucrats like you know
bureaucrats who are who are on our side
you're still going to need um you know
you're still going to need warm bodies
to uh to do this and unfortunately i
don't think we we have them as of yet we
have not trained them um i think
rather than train them up for going to
dc and to work in some of these
departments we should train them up to
work in red states because uh because
there's certainly a need for that well
you've given me quite a segue because
the final story today
is that there is a rumor going around
that you can no longer say gay
in florida people are freaking out the
white house tweeted this
today conservative politicians in
florida advance legislation designed to
attack lgbtqi
plus kids
instead of making growing up harder for
young people potus is focused on keeping
schools open
and supporting students mental health
now
what this is referring to
is this bill that is being pushed by
desantis that they're trying to get some
of this gender lunacy
out of the schools this has nothing to
do with you can't say gay this has
nothing to do with not treating anyone
equally under the law or anything else
but brad palumbo who's been on the show
and as a writer for washington examiner
he unpacked it a little more cleanly
that he tells us about the bill it
simply prohibits a school district from
encouraging classroom discussion about
sexual orientation or gender identity in
primary grade levels the proposed law
also specifies encouragement of
discussion on these topics that cannot
be done in a manner that is not age
appropriate or developmentally
appropriate for students importantly
this bill does not prohibit students
from having these discussions on their
own initiative discussions of sexuality
and gender identity simply can't be
forced by the schools now of course the
white house put our gay transportation
secretary pete buddha buddha judge out
there to say how homophobic this whole
thing is everyone's running around
saying desantis hates gay people all the
usual nonsense but literally this is
just about are we going to indoctrinate
these kids
in third fourth grade about issues that
let them talk about it in eighth ninth
grade perhaps or leave that to the
parents or home school or whatever else
uh
john i suppose this doesn't surprise you
when they try to pass something that's
to stop lunacy that they get called the
bigots and the rest of it
yeah not at all i mean look they they'll
try to sell you this white house and and
the corporate media that pete
is the first senate confirmed to gain
cabinet level appointee that's not true
it was rick grinnell yep as acting dni
he had an ambassador to germany very
good friend of mine and yours dave yeah
the history
left leftist history corporate media
history has bypassed rick cornell and
and uh no this doesn't surprise me i
think brad palumbo did a phenomenal job
of unpacking this he debunked
their entire argument far better than i
could the only last point i'll make is
to the last segment where's the downside
in not appointing 15 000 bureaucrats we
should see that as a
as a massive conservative win but now
this is just more lunacy you know what
it is desantis is doing so well and i'm
not a offender for anybody i'll
criticize anyone that's well documented
but
the old saying is true when you're
taking flack you're over the target and
when you're taking indiscriminate flat
you're over a very nervous target and
that's where the sentence is right now
they don't have anything to throw at him
so they're rolling out the old he's a
racist he's homophobic he's a bigot
argument they're falling on deaf ears
they're not moving the political needle
i think if anything parents like carol
are going to read colombo's version of
events and it's only going to raise the
status of stock in there
well carol take it away
so
you know it's it's funny and i know that
you three know this but i'm sort of the
squish in the room on trans stuff i
think conservatives aren't really
handling it the way that i would prefer
maybe that's a different conversation um
but i think if you read this bill it's
specifically about grade school and i
think that you know i got all these
comments on twitter when i pointed out
that the media was following obviously
the don't say gay labeling of the
leftist groups the media literally runs
that in the headlines um i got all these
comments being like a high school gay
student gay student can't say that
they're get you know it's like people do
not understand what it's about at all um
i had a mom in staten island in brooklyn
which is a conservative part i'm sorry
staten island in new york a conservative
part of new york where her second grader
the they read this book called um you
know as an avocado a fruit or a
vegetable and it led to this whole
discussion about like can you change
your gender it's second grade like a
second grader is extremely susceptible
to outside opinion um and i think we
really don't realize that small kids
really do pick up a lot from their
teachers i did i read this bill it's
really short everybody should read it um
i don't understand
where in this bill it says you can say
gay it's about not discussing um sexual
orientation and straight is also a
sexual orientation so i don't get where
um that comes from i i genuinely don't
and again i am the squish on this call i
have had trans friends in my life i uh
think you know there are there is such a
thing as trans people um and a lot of it
is just i we just don't talk about it
the right way but for kids i think
there's a bright line and this bill
makes that line bright that's exactly
what it does and i have no problem with
it right so as far as where it comes
from i think where it comes from is sort
of what john just said which is if you
do anything against these people they'll
just say the horrible things about you i
saw all sorts of people saying okay now
you can't come out of the closet if
you're in high school and of course
that's not true there's people were
saying oh they're gonna now they can
openly discriminate uh you know against
a third grader if he has two dads of
course that's not true it's all like
it's literally at every level nonsense
so dave this is all right let me just
add the bill specifies actually also
it's about fostering discussion so like
if um a teacher can actually say i'm gay
i'm married you know i'm a man married
to a man i'm a woman marital and that's
fine as long as you're then not like hey
second graders what do you think about
that like it's literally about fostering
discussion not about mentioning anything
to do with gay or trans or any of it
right and again the only reason they're
even doing something like this is
because these people have pushed all of
the gender identity confusion on these
kids in the first place and just for the
record i have no problem with anyone
that's trans you can live your life
however you want to live
but we can put that aside uh dave final
thought on all of this and then i'll let
you guys go and get prepared for a big
florida weekend i assume you all have
awesome things to do you know wrestling
alligators and things um from a media
perspective is there anything desantis
should be doing differently on this kind
of stuff he knows he's going to get hit
on it that we know they're going to lie
we know that biden will lie buddha judge
will lie the media will parrot it is
there anything else he can do on that
front or that we should do actually i
would
yeah i mean i this was this was going to
be my angle too which is uh this is a
test for desantis and one that i think
i'm pretty sure he's going to pass which
is to say
that the trap that they're laying for
him is to get him to sort of you know
respond to this in a very defensive
mainstream
establishment gop way which is to say oh
no i'm gonna now spend you know a half
an hour talking about how much i love
trans people how much i love trans kids
but just this one thing is maybe going
too far
um i think the answer to that is you
know l-o-l-g-f
um
you know we we we've we've absolutely
had enough um i think it's it's it's
pretty funny that the same day that this
popped into the news
was the the uh it was the same day that
the department of energy goes and hires
a completely insane person yeah um who
was he was another one of these um uh
you know alphabet uh gender
uh uh crusaders who who you know
whatever likes to pretend to be a dog or
you know or or something like this we'll
let people google this on their own or
maybe not yeah yeah i mean i i think
that that people are now seeing that
we're dealing with utter depravity and
you know i mean let's just go and say it
these people are groomers
um the the obsession that the that that
these activists these gender activists
have with
children
you know at this age you know whatever
you know five through eight
and uh and and sexualizing them i mean
it's it's it's completely insane i think
it's uh it's it's not even a um
uh it's not even debatable what these
people are doing and and and what uh
what what they'd like to do and uh the
more that people see it i mean people
see what you know who are the craziest
people on on tick tock you know we have
the libs of tick tock account the
craziest people are the primary school
teachers
and um
and people are seeing this and and i
think they're disgusted and increasingly
they will turn to politicians who will
have no apologies in saying absolutely
not we draw a red line all right you
know what i can't quite end on that note
for a florida show so i will kick it to
each one of you
for if you were to welcome if there were
people that are watching this right now
there's an awful lot of people watching
that are thinking about moving to
florida i mean that's what i get
messages about more than anything else
these days what would be your one
message to someone that was moving to
florida right now john you've been here
the longest so i'll let you go first
take a look behind me this is my office
it's a beach club i don't even have
walls or windows
come on down you'll love it
carol
i would say you remember what normal
life was like you remember what it was
like not to treat other people like
disease vectors you remember what it was
like for your kids to be able to smile
at school you can live all of that here
it's back to normal here and normal is
amazing
dave don't say anything about the
traffic this is it this is the big
finish come on
i would say
you know i would agree with everyone
else it's it's amazing here i will
probably never leave if i leave here
it'll be you know to to uh to
escape the united states completely
um
but uh but i would say you know if you
come here make sure and take advantage
of the real you know the real florida
the real miami you know don't just go to
the uh you know to the tourist traps
don't just go to uh to the places that
the hip you know hot spots that everyone
goes to uh you know discover the cuban
neighborhoods discover the brazilian
neighborhoods and and uh because there's
there's an amazing world here
ain't it the truth all right guys i'm
gonna finish up without you but have a
great weekend i know we'll we'll all be
seeing each other pretty soon and uh
florida it's just fantastic have a good
weekend guys
uh and for
for everybody else uh i'm digging these
florida colors actually maybe this will
be the the new friday the casual friday
that we'll do around here um
i just want to say that i i think this
week was probably maybe it's not my
place to say it exactly but i think in
some ways this past week uh what we did
on this show was probably the most
rewarding week that i've had
in terms of content and messaging and
doing what i'm supposed to be doing
maybe since really the beginnings of
this thing back in like 2015 or
something i think what we did
with rumble making the offer to joe
rogan defending free speech and not just
talking about it but putting our money
where our mouth is it's actually
irrelevant whether he takes us up on the
offer uh or not
we put our best
foot forward on that i think you know
talking as much as we did about all of
this canadian trucker stuff as they get
lambasted in the media and lied about
you know exposing all of the nonsense at
cnn and the way these people lie it's
like i think
we've got a chance i really do think
we've got a chance and i think ground
zero for that chance is right here in
florida which is exactly why i wanted to
do our first panel the way we did just
now so uh again it's probably not for me
to say that it's probably for you guys
to say that uh but i hope you have a
great weekend i hope that you see some
of the signs now there are signs there
are signals all over the place the
truckers did something in canada not
because they're transphobes and racists
but because they wanted to live freely
and now their country is starting to
open up for now but they probably will
have to keep the pressure on
not only that but then it leaked into
the united states it's not a coincidence
that as people saw the people of canada
stand up that suddenly our blue state
democrat
you know governors and authorities we're
suddenly like oh we'll open up too and
we'll get the kids out of masks and
everything else and if you've seen the
videos that they're showing now from
these schools where the teachers
announced the kids are ripping off the
mask you know you can take off your mask
now and they rip them off and they're
the joy the sheer exuberance that these
kids are showing it's incredible we will
get back to being human but we'll only
do it if we say we're the ones that are
gonna make it happen that's what those
guys did up in canada uh that's what
we'll continue to do here have a great
weekend everybody and we'll see you on
monday
you